(dramatic music)
- [Narrator] In the middle
of a political upheaval,
one Ukrainian zookeeper set
out to make a difference
in his own way, on the private estate
of an ousted president.
(mellow music)
Sergey used to be a
zoologist at the Kiev Zoo.
(Sergey speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] One night in
2014, he was watching the news
and learned that amidst the chaos,
Ukrainian president Viktor Yanukovych
had fled his compound in Mezhyhirya,
leaving his private zoo behind.
(Sergey speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] When he
arrived, Sergey was stunned
by the huge opulent estate
and saw the animals needed desperate care.
(Sergey speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] What he thought
might be just a few days,
has turned into four years.
(Sergey speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] Today, Sergey
and a handful of volunteers
take care of thousands
of animals on the estate.
(Sergey speaking in foreign language)
(mellow piano music)
- [Narrator] The zoo is slowly growing,
and Sergey has big hopes for the future.
(Sergey speaking in foreign language)
(bright music)